why make a feature why not stick with
shorts right you you had to make this
feature why what was it to be honest I I
was talking about that with a professor
of mine at UCLA who is with his correct
prediction pony who is a veteran in a
hand and anyways like don't make a
feature once you you're out of him
school film school is great place to
make short and I did a bunch of shorts
at UCLA to learn i was learning like
that but it's true that one advice I
would have is don't lose time on doing
shorts I mean there are so many people
there who are making films and killing
themselves directors that I think that
the right now times have changed and
it's not like it used to be with the
Spielberg Lucas who get famous because
of their shorts and get access to a
bigger thing because of their shorts
nowadays I mean we are in the time of
digital cinema and getting pretty usable
camera is pretty cheap you can even do
it with your iPhone and so it's so about
people are going to judge if you are
able to hold a long time and be able to
make a true feature film so I was like I
don't want to make it short anymore so
let's do a feature film and this is
after how many shorts I did three or
four shots at UCLA okay so you were
saying this is it yeah this is
you